ah ah ah
[Musique]
you locaux mon petit renne hyper actifs
préférés
[Musique]
je m'appelle noël kringen bonjour toi
seul mon costume avec les petits sapins
a besoin d'être nettoyé
ou alors mon voeux de noël vient juste
de se réaliser noël c'est une histoire
de famille et mon père était le père
noël est maintenant c'est mon frère nick
qui lui succède une chaussure rempli de
cailloux ils méritent pas mieux
il se souvient chatons au sommet d'un
vernis gentil alors noël est ce que ton
frère va être prêt pour noël
oui bien sûr c'est pas trés n'y passe
pas bien tu trouve quelquefois
j'aimerais tellement tout quitter qui
peut pas être le père noël si tu
souffrent d'une dépression nerveuse
tu devrais être opposés et partir ce
week-end bon la première fois en plus de
deux mille ans le père noël a disparu
je vais juste dit de profiter de ce week
end il nous faut un nouveau père noël
gabriel créé une gueule moi je travaille
au service informatique et j'aime ce que
je fais lançant une mission récupération
tu veux bien dire ce que tu fais j'ai
pas cherché mon frère et tu viens avec
moi
[Musique]
est ce que vous êtes nous cherchons le
père noël
le dis à personne qui tu es vous venez
d'où une petite ville dans le nord ni
d'où tu viens
monsieur c'est un privilège de porter ce
costume alors mettez au pentagone jeh
lundi dont deux jours c'est noël je
crois que c'est le moment idéal pour
lancer une nouvelle plate forme de
livraison en ligne se trouvait le père
noël copte de milan nous apportons des
jouets aux enfants
il n'est pas question que ça change
tellement chaud est ce qu est la glace
dans cette ville bonjour j'adore votre
pantalon très joli c'est un pantalon de
yoga comme le vôtre j'ai mis du yogourt
sur mon pantalon
non non de yoga j'adore le yogourt
[Musique]
position du renne inversée je t'avais
dit de partir en week-end pourquoi tu
m'écoutes jamais ça s'il te plaît ouah
c'est très symbolique ici